in almost all aspect of our lives we
have perfect information available
instantaneously my phone can tell me
everything about my finances where
precisely I am on a map and the best way
to my next destination all with the
click of a button
but this availability of information and
transparency almost completely
disappears when it comes to consumer
products if you go to the seafood
counter at your local supermarket you
can probably choose between several
different types of fish but chances are
they won't be able to tell you who
caught the fish where precisely it was
caught whether it is sustainable to
catch it there and how it got
transported and that holds true for
almost everything we buy every can of
soup every piece of meat every t-shirt
we as humans right now are destroying
the only thing we really need to survive
our planet and most of the horrible
problems that we're facing today like
climate change and modern slavery and
supply chains come down to decisions
human decisions to produce something one
way and not another and that's how we as
consumers end up making decisions that
harm the planet or our fellow humans by
choosing the wrong products but I refuse
to believe that anybody here in this
room or frankly anybody on this planet
really wants to buy a product that harms
the planet or our fellow humans if given
the choice but you see choice is a
loaded word choice means there's another
option choice means you can afford that
option but choice also means you have
enough information to make an informed
decision and that information nowadays
simply just doesn't exist or at least is
really really hard to access
but I think this is about to change
because we can use technology to solve
this information problem and many of the
specific technologies that we need to do
that have become better and cheaper over
the recent years and are now ready to be
used at scale so over the past two years
my team and I have been working with one
of the world's largest conservation
organizations WWF and we've founded a
company called open SC where s C stands
for supply chain and we believe that by
using technology we can help to create
transparency and traceability in supply
chains and through that help to
completely revolutionize the way that we
buy and also produce products as humans
now some of this is gonna sound a little
bit like science fiction but it's
already happening let me explain so in
order to solve this information problem
we need to do three things
verify trace and share verify a specific
sustainability and ethical production
claims in a database and automated way
then trace those individual physical
products throughout their supply chains
and finally share that information with
consumers in a way that truly gives them
a choice and lets to make consumption
decisions that are more aligned with
their values I'm gonna use a real
product and a supply chain where we've
made all of this a reality already a
Patagonian toothfish or Chilean sea bass
as it's called in the US number one
verify verify how something is produced
but not just by saying trust me this is
good trust me we've done all the right
things but by producing evidence for
that individual physical product and the
way it was produced by producing
evidence for a specific sustainability
or ethical production claim so for
example in the case of the fish has this
fish been caught in an area where
there's enough of them so that it's
sustainable to catch it there and not in
a marine protected area
so what we're doing here is we're taking
almost real-time GPS data from the ship
the ship that's fishing and that tells
us where the ship is and where it's
going at what speed and we can then
combine that with other types of data
like for example how deep the sea floor
is and combining all of this information
our machine learning algorithms can then
verify in an automated way whether the
ship is only fishing where it's supposed
to or not and as sensors become cheaper
we can put them in more places and that
means we can capture more data and
combining that with advancements in data
science it means that we can now verify
specific sustainability and ethical
production claims in an automated
real-time and ongoing manner and that
really lays the basis for this
information revolution so number two
trace trace those individual physical
products so that we can truly say that
the claim that we verified about a
certain product actually belongs to that
individual product that we as consumers
have right in front of us because
without that level of traceability all
that we've really verified in the first
place is that somebody somewhere at some
point caught a fish in a sustainable way
or didn't harm the employee when asking
them to produce a t-shirt or didn't use
pesticides when growing a vegetable that
didn't actually need it only if I give a
product and identity from the start and
then trace it throughout the whole
supply chain can this claim and the
value that's been created by producing
it in the right way truly stay with it
now I've talked about cheaper sensors
there are many other technological
developments that make all of this much
more possible today than ever before
for example the falling costs of tags
you give a product a name a serial
number an identity the tag is its
passport what you can see here is a
tooth fish being caught this
is what's called a longline fishery so
the fish are coming up onto the boat on
individual hooks and as soon as the fish
is on board it is killed and then after
that we insert a small tag into the
fished flesh and in that tag there is an
RFID chip with a unique serial number
and that tag follows the fish throughout
the whole supply chain and makes it
really easy to sense its presence in any
port on any truck or in any processing
plant but consumers can't really read
RFID tags and so when it comes to
filling and packaging the fish we read
the RFID tag and then remove it and then
we add a unique QR code to the packaging
of the fish and that QR code then points
back to the same information that we've
verified about the fish in the first
place
and so depending on the type of product
that we're working with we may use QR
codes barcodes RFID tags or other tag
technologies but there are also
technologies that are at the brink of
large-scale breakthrough that make tags
themselves obsolete
like for example analyzing a product for
trace elements that can then tell you
quite accurately where it is actually
from then there's blockchain
decentralized technology can act as a
catalyst for this revolution because it
can help mitigate some of the trust
issues that are inherent to giving
people information and then asking them
to change their consumption behavior
because of that information and so we
use blockchain technology where it adds
value to what we're doing but
importantly we don't let the limitations
that this technology still has today
like for example with regards to scaling
we don't let that stand in our way and
that brings us to the third point share
how to share the information that we've
verified and tracked about where product
is from how it was produced and how it
got to where it is how to share this
information is really different from
product to product and different from
where you buy it you behave differently
in those situations you are stressed and
time poor and
per market or with short attention span
over dinner because your date so cute or
you are critical and inquisitive when
researching for a larger purchase online
and so for our fish we've developed a
digital experience that works when
buying the fish in a freezer in a fish
specialty store and that gives you all
of the information about the fish in its
journey but we also worked with a
restaurant and developed a different
digital experience that only summarizes
the key facts about the fish in its
journey and works better in a dinner
setting and hopefully there doesn't
annoy your date too much now that brings
us full circle we've verified that the
fish was caught in an area where it's
sustainable to do so we've then traced
it throughout the entire supply chain to
maintain its identity and all the
information that's attached to it and
then we've shared that information with
consumers in a way that gives them a
choice and lets to make consumption
decisions that are more in line with
their values now for this fish example
this is already rolled out at scale this
season the entire fleet of the world's
largest two fish fishing company Austral
fisheries is tagging every single fish
that they catch and that ends up in
their premium branded glacier 51 product
and you can already buy this fish and
with it you can have all of the
information I talked about today and
much more attached to each individual
fish or portion of the fish that you may
buy but this is not a fish or seafood
thing we're working on many many
different commodities and products and
their supply chains across the globe
from dairy to fruit and vegetables to
non-food products made out of wood as a
consumer all of this may sound like a
huge burden because you don't have time
to look at all of this information every
time you buy something and I don't
expect you to because you'll have help
with that in the future we'll leave the
decision of which specific
product to buy increasingly up to
machines an algorithm will know enough
about you to make those decisions for
you so you don't have to and maybe it'll
even do a better job at it in a recent
study 85% of those buying a product
through a virtual assistant said that
they on occasion actually went with the
top product recommendation of that
virtual assistant rather than the
specific product or brand that they set
out to buy in the first place
you just say you need toilet paper it's
then an algorithm that decides which
brand price point or whether you go with
recycled or not well nowadays this is
usually based on what you bought in the
past or whoever pays the most to the
company behind the virtual assistant but
why shouldn't that be also based on your
values knowing that you want to buy
planet-friendly and knowing whether and
how much you're willing and able to pay
for that now that will make it easy and
seamless but still based on granule
effects and data to choose the right
products not by necessarily doing it
yourself but by asking an algorithm that
knows how much you care about this
planet not by necessarily doing it
yourself but by asking in algorithm that
is never time poor distracted or with
short attention span because of the cute
date and that knows how much you care
about this planet and the people living
on it by asking that algorithm to look
at all of that information for you and
to decide for you if we have reliable
and trustworthy information like that
and the right systems that make use of
it consumers will support those who are
doing the right thing by producing
products in a sustainable and ethical
way they will support them every time by
choosing their goods over others and
that means that good producers and
processors and retailers will get
rewarded and bad actors will be forced
to adjust their practices or get out of
business and we need that
if we want to continue to live together
on this beautiful planet we really need
it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]